okay this morning I was browsing the
David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it some very very
exciting things being discussed there
including that james d'amore will be on
the david pakman show james d'amour is
the Google employee who was fired for
criticizing Google's diversity policy in
a shared document that ultimately was
shared with more people than maybe James
d'amour originally intended he'll be
joining me for a two-part interview next
week and I am glad to take questions
from the audience I think it'll be an
interesting interview for sure he was
accused of perpetuating gender
stereotypes yes I think is an allegation
that goes too far and it'll be
interesting to see him on the program
yes it will and he will be on so please
get your questions in for James d'amour
also an interesting post the Democratic
Party is trying to manipulate the
primary by bringing the California
primary early which would make it harder
for Less finance less well known
candidates to build up the momentum I
was not aware of the effort that
California was looking at to make their
primary earlier typically the reason for
moving a primary earlier as states want
to be sort of like the bellwether the
first primary to get a bunch of
attention like Iowa Iowa for example
there's no reason that says Iowa has to
be the first primary but it is and this
seems to be a different impetus at least
according to this visitor to the David
Pakman show subreddit is it right to
politicize 9/11 a very interesting
discussion on the David Pakman show
subreddit about the politicizing of 9/11
every time it comes around and we know
about Rudy 9/11 Giuliani's use of 9/11
we know about other elected officials
using 9/11 but it's an interesting
discussion about whether it is okay or
right to politicize 9/11 and then lastly
from our reddit discussion forum these
are all conversations you can
participate in by the way a david
pakman.com slash read it National I'm
sorry natural disaster thought
experiment for all backup generators at
your hospitals fail patients must be
prioritized for airlift evacuation staff
must decide and
who do you evacuate first who goes last
which is sort of like a not so much a
trolley problem question but as sort of
a triage question right and people
participating and saying here's how I
would decide the order of evacuation in
a natural disaster of patients from a
hospital had to go some of those
decisions are pretty complex and I I've
not I'm glad I don't work in a field
where I have to make those types of
decisions especially in the context of
hurricane EMA now where I guess there
was quite a few elderly people at a
nursing home who unfortunately passed
away because they their generator was
operating but the air conditioning
wasn't working so I felt that 105
degrees there yeah horrible horrible
stories that came out of nursing homes
related to the hurricane participate
start your own topic if you want at
david pakman.com slash read it